I would like to tell you all that I
successfully quit smoking I did it
cigarettes I'm done
again using toothpicks not on toothpicks
all day like trying not to rip my face
off but non-stop toothpick gnawing and
one day my friend out of support says
you know what though you look cool
smoking smoking cigarette doesn't look
nearly as cool as chewing on a toothpick
you look like a rebel no I don't look
like a rebel I'm fat I look like I just
ate again so a toothpick makes me look
the 3rd supper was delicious
who is pre breakfast can I sleep first I
mean this is this is who I am like check
it you know this is part of my life this
is how I meet women I make eye contact
with a beautiful woman
let's say ugh you like this you come
home with me tonight you could look like
this in nine months and then I do that
and just pull
so people have told me my entire life
that I look like an owl if you don't see
it don't worry I do and that's the most
important thing every time I look into a
mirror oh my god there I am
owl boy that's me I should find myself a
wizard perched myself on his shoulder
get some squawking done that's what I am
and I'm like flattered with the
comparison to an owl because they live
amazing lives like what do I always do
first of all they sleep all day that's
awesome I love doing that they hang out
in their tree at night they're nocturnal
they have 2010 vision which means they
can see 90 seconds into the future which
is insane
when they see something they want let's
say it's like a dirty old field mouse
the owl that lets out a shriek so loud
and blood-curdling that that Mouse
becomes paralyzed in fear it can't move
it's too afraid then seconds later the
owl swoops in stuff like and that Mouse
is gone forever never existed jealous
what an amazing way to live your life
see something you want shriek at it till
it's too terrified to move swoop in make
it yours people have told me that I look
like I'm capable of such things I mean
you should see me pick up on women for
real that's what I do I hang out and in
a bar doing my thing she freezes up in a
panic I swoop in
oh she's usually gone that's how I get
point A to point B it's very difficult
to swoop without a wingspan and women
aren't like mice you can't just shrink
out and expect them to stay put remember
that
I've quit smoking weed as well I know I
know what a what a dumbass
so stupid what a dumb choice all these
extra hours of mental clarity that I
have I hate them they suck I mean it's
sad for me knowing that I will never
again watch all five Air Bud films
back-to-back ever again
yeah I will never again make a tuna mac
cake and eat it all by myself those days
are gone for me I will never again go to
a party notice how many people are
wearing hats and get weirded out by that
and just leave anything penciler that
thing is like my I can't smoke weed
anymore my brain my brain has become
like a jerk like an older brother just
picks on me all the time so when I would
get high
my brain would lay seriously you just
spoke Twitty fine now guess who's gonna
be terrified of circles for the next
four and a half hours
so anybody here a fan of REM are you now
I am talking about the band not actual
rapid eye movement that's it I'd sleep
everybody loves that everyone's a fan
Artie I'm Lisa we broke up and that's
pretty sad and the best way to pay
homage to a great band like REM is to
sing REM songs in public like you're an
old-timey drunk Mexican I don't think
you trust me enough to follow me on that
path so let me just demonstrate for you
what I mean if the end of the world as
we know it I feel fine
everybody hurts sometimes sometimes
everybody cries do you believe they put
a man on the moon
hang on the moon if you're not laughing
at this no that's because you're a dirty
racist thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]